[Music]
we've all had tough days at the office
but some actors dedicated to giving it
their all took their work a few steps
too far though these critically
acclaimed often award-winning
performances are a delight to watch the
experience of preparing for and
recovering from these roles did a number
on the actors involved and left a
lasting impression not always for the
positive here are several actors who
went the extra mile for their craft
Isabella Johnny possession any horror
buff knows the subway scene in Andre
jalevsky's 1981 possession to be one of
the most horrifying shocking moments of
body horror ever to Grace the Silver
Screen and if you haven't seen the film
buckle up you're in for a treat Isabella
Johnny won a Caesar award for her
performance but the intense physical and
emotional demands of the role made for
an extremely difficult recuperation
Ajani later told a French magazine that
it took her years of therapy to get Anna
out of her system and that she would
never again attempt another role like it
Adrian Brody The Pianist
though Brody's physical transformation
for 2002's The Pianist is obvious the
actor has also discussed the enormous
mental and emotional strain of
portraying a holocaust Survivor which
earned him the Academy Award for best
actor in 2003. you know my experiences
of making this film made me very aware
of the sadness
and the dehumanization of people at
times of War to prepare for the role
Brody gave up his apartment sold his car
disconnected his phones and moved to
Europe but it was the emotional effect
of intense hunger during his extreme
crash diet that he found the most
surprising and difficult challenge to
deal with Brody told the BBC I've
experienced loss I've experienced
sadness in my life but I didn't know the
desperation that comes with Hunger there
were moments when he wasn't sure he'd
get out of the experience with his
sanity intact saying it took a year and
a half to quote settle back into things
Colin Firth The King's Speech Colin
Firth plays the Future King of England
George VI and the oscar-winning The
King's Speech and has to give a number
of speeches in addition to a number of
other Royal duties the film has a
villain of sorts in the form of a near
debilitating stammer that ruins nearly
every speech George gives until he hires
a vocal coach Prince Albert Frederick
Arthur
George ferth himself also worked closely
with the voice coach and watched
recordings of George speaking to better
emulate both his vocal shortcomings as
well as his physical mannerisms and
nervous ticks when stammering Firth
immersed himself so deeply in the role
that he admitted in an interview that he
still occasionally lapsed into the
stammer when speaking casually even
briefly stammering during the interview
itself it's worth noting that this
happened in May of 2011 a full eight
months after the film premiered in
September of the previous year judging
by how flawlessly he enunciated every
syllable in kingsman the Secret Service
while taking down thugs with an umbrella
in 2014 it looks like Firth has since
gotten over the stammer Hugh Laurie
house during the casting process of
house the producers famously explained
that they wanted a quintessentially
American actor to play Dr house shortly
before hiring British actor Hugh Laurie
Laurie apparently got the role because
his American accent on his audition tape
was so convincing nobody realized he was
British the director of the pilot even
pointed to the tape and said see this is
what I want an american guy I was
expecting in my office 20 minutes ago
really that's all because I have no
intention of being in your office 20
minutes ago Lori also really went for it
when it came to walking with a limp to
portray the cane using house so much so
the actor still walked with a limp in
2015 after eight straight years of
pretending to have one on set Lori also
reportedly attempted to ease the load on
his leg by occasionally switching the
leg with the limp something he claims
nobody ever noticed or called him on
during filming or in the years since the
show ended apparently Lori's acting is
so good he can make people Overlook both
his britishness and the fact he didn't
always limp with the same leg despite
that being a defining aspect of the
character Bob Hoskins Who Framed Roger
Rabbit one of late British actor Hoskins
most famous roles was that of alcoholic
La gumshoe Eddie valenth in the film Who
Framed Roger Rabbit Hoskins had to spend
several hours a day for eight months
talking to and acting alongside cartoon
characters who weren't really there
scotch on the rocks
and I mean ice Hoskins would later note
that he learned how to hallucinate that
Roger and the other characters were
actually there to cope with the
dissonance of constantly hearing their
voices but never seeing them while
filming when shooting finally ended
Hoskins found himself constantly talking
to himself and even hallucinating that
Roger was sitting in the same room for
months afterwards prompting his doctor
to advise him to take a much needed
break from acting Heath Ledger The Dark
Knight Ledger's performance as the Joker
in The Dark Knight was so chilling that
it landed him an Oscar for best
supporting actor tragically it was a
posthumous award as Ledger had died of
an accidental overdose in January 2008.
does it depress you commissioner
to know
just how alone you really are in the
years that followed his premature death
rumors swirled that the preparation for
the dark role had contributed to
Ledger's demise before filming began
Ledger put himself in a strict isolation
keeping a diary of disturbing images to
enter the realm of a psychopath he
sometimes only slept two hours a night
while filming according to a November
2007 interview with the New York Times
it was a mixture of painkillers
anti-anxiety drugs and sleeping pills
that ultimately caused Ledger's death
just two months later Charlie Hunnam
American TV and movies Charlie Hunnam
has played everything from a soccer
hooligan to a giant robot pilot and he's
known for his extraordinarily convincing
American accent making him one of a
handful of chameleon-like British actors
able to convincingly pass as American in
his various roles you rescued her
raised her you're not protecting her now
you are holding her back Years of Living
in the states however took their toll on
hunting's actual real life accent and
when he appeared on TV in 2013 to plug a
movie on Conan he spoke with the bizarre
amalgamation of various American
dialects that prompted confusion and
mockery especially in hanum's Native UK
when I went out just as he was rounding
the side of the house and he stopped and
I looked to them and I said so we got
business mother
Harlem spoke about this in 2017 when he
admitted that his accent or lack thereof
had gotten so bad that when he signed
onto the star in King Arthur legend of
the sword he had to hire a dialect coach
to relearn how to speak with an English
accent for the first time in my career
my name was above the title it's a
Charlie Hunnam boom King Arthur I said
here we go
Janet Lee Psycho Academy award-winning
actress Janet Lee is known mainly for
one role playing the character who gets
stabbed to death in a shower early on in
Alfred Hitchcock's Psycho the scene
terrified Millions including Lee after
filming raps she never felt comfortable
in a shower again in interviews Lee
noted that she stopped taking showers
after watching the scene I still
I still don't take showers that's the
truth on the rare occasion she had to
take a shower she would only use it
briefly while staring directly at the
door and she wouldn't even draw the
shower curtain James Cromwell babe James
Cromwell is the kind of actor whose
appearance is so distinctive most people
know his face but not his name he scored
one of his few leading film roles in
1995's babe in which he was upstaged by
a talking pig but it all worked out
given that it was not only a massive hit
but it changed cromwell's life turning
him from a guy who occasionally flirted
with vegetarianism into a vegan Cromwell
has called the experience of making the
film a turning point in his life
recalling in an interview with Vice that
he was profoundly affected by seeing a
small piglet react to being put onto a
patch of grass he said quote when that
little pig was put down on that big
pitch and saw the blue sky and the Green
Grass and the sea that pig just took off
and said I don't want any part of this
I'm out Cromwell has been an art and
supporter of animal rights ever since
especially pigs which understandably now
have a small place in his heart thanks
to babe and its sequel babe too a pig in
the city I know that I'm aware of their
suffering and I know that I have an
obligation to talk about their suffering
and to do something about their
suffering
Christopher McDonald Happy Gilmore
Christopher McDonald isn't exactly a
household name but his performance in
Happy Gilmore is so memorable that
generations of film goers can't look at
a picture of his face without blurting
out hey it's Shooter McGavin that's just
one roll out of many in a solid career
but it looks like McDonald doesn't mind
being forever associated with a
hot-headed golf pro McDonald told the AV
club he took the role basically because
he enjoyed playing golf and won a
tournament shortly after being offered
the script he was hesitant at first
saying he wasn't eager to get back on a
film set after shooting two movies back
to back but being paid to play golf and
hang out with Adam Sandler seemed like a
pretty sweet deal according to McDonald
his golf team got sick since he played
for five hours a day six days a week
while filming and as an added bonus now
that he's synonymous with Shooter
McGavin he basically gets to play golf
for free for the rest of his life
[Music]
all right
[Music]
Sons of Anarchy ran from 2008 through
2014 and Charlie Hunnam remained an
audience favorite throughout the entire
run but what happened to him after the
last episode it seems like hunting
hasn't been quite the same since Sons of
Anarchy ended
moving on from a role after a beloved TV
show ends is never easy for an actor
especially when they've been playing
that character for several years for
hanum saying goodbye to Jack's teller
was difficult in fact the way he
describes the experience makes it sound
as though he went through a bit of a
grieving process Hannah was
overwhelmingly nostalgic for his time on
Sons of Anarchy and he admitted that he
would make up excuses to visit the set
and relive his days on the show he told
glamor I knew the security guards and
for a couple of days said oh I forgot
something so they'd let me onto the set
and I'd just walk around at night
because I wanted to be in that
environment and go through a personal
process of saying goodbye
for six years Hunnam knew that he had a
secure paycheck as Jax Teller but once
the show finished its run he was
responsible for making big decisions
about his next career-defining move and
he felt very intimidated by the process
Haram says that he struggles with
insecurity when it comes to maintaining
a career as an actor he told the talks
it's a tricky thing to quantify one's
career because in some ways I am in a
position where I want to be I'm getting
to work with good directors and tell
interesting stories but I always feel
like I am one failed movie away from
being unemployable here we go right and
only up from from here on now
hanum isn't a fan of the process of
choosing roles and he doesn't enjoy
feeling the pressure to succeed at the
box office every time
it's no secret that hanum is well known
for his good looks but he's an actor at
heart not a model and he wants to earn
respect and attention for his talents he
became uncomfortable with the way some
people perceived him during his time on
Sons of Anarchy as someone who coasted
to fame on physical appearance alone
when it comes to how other people see
him hanum told in style I try not to
think about that too much because I'm
just attempting to shape my own
perception of myself and feel confident
in my own identity Haram then admitted
there will always be people who see him
as just the quote pretty boy but despite
the stigma he still wants to face a
challenge of making each and every
performance work to the best of his
ability
when Haram was young he lived in a rough
neighborhood so he always had to know
how to defend himself and when he signed
on to the film King Arthur legend of the
sword he had to go through an intense
training regimen which included learning
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu Hunnam ended up
getting super into the sport and he
started feeling the benefits of
consistent practice in fact he says that
Jiu Jitsu changed his mindset he told
Men's Health it's not even as much the
physical benefit of training it's the
mental when you're training every day in
a combat discipline it just gives you
that eye of the tiger even after
shooting for King Arthur ended hanum
stuck with Jiu Jitsu and earned his blue
belt in 2018. Hunter's new hobby seems
to have had a profound impact on him
after all he doesn't do anything halfway
and it's probably a good idea for
everyone to stay on his good side now
hanum doesn't think that Fame and wealth
are necessarily indicators of success he
says he actually prefers to work on
smaller projects with less Financial
backing because he feels like the
director has more creative control in
that scenario as opposed to focusing on
accolades and high salaries he says he
just wants to challenge himself create
films that he's proud of and work
alongside directors who have interesting
ideas he told uprox if I'm involved in a
project that I feel excited about and it
gives me a sense of purpose and it gives
me a sense of creative fulfillment that
is deep fulfillment to me and it evens
out the balance for me in my own Journey
my success for me is about getting to
continue to work on things that make me
excited it seems like hanum has had a
lot to reflect on since Sons of Anarchy
ended and he's confident about the
direction he's going in now
[Music]
Edward Norton was deeply affected by the
experience of making American History X
partly due to the film's dark subject
matter and partly because the production
was a very troubled one here's why the
actor was never quite the same after
making this film in 1996 Norton's
performance in Primal Fear established
him as a formidable talent but it was
his starring role in 1998's American
History X that truly showcased his
talents in the film Norton plays Derek
Vineyard a Neo-Nazi who abandons his
ideology after spending some time in
prison he then tries to prevent his
younger brother Dany played by Edward
Furlong from following in his footsteps
as Norton told GQ in 2019 the film was
like even the poster was iconic it was a
Shakespearean
type of a story by Design it's rare that
an actor has to step in and edit the
film they're starring in but that's
exactly what Edward Norton ended up
doing that's because the making of
American History X proved to be almost
as controversial as the film itself and
the film was plenty controversial
[Music]
in the middle of the editing process
director Tony K had some serious
creative differences with the production
company new line Cinema K had previously
worked as an advertising director in his
experience in that industry reportedly
affected his editing decisions in fact
David McKenna the film's screenwriter
told the telegraph that K literally
destroyed the movie It was a commercial
in the hopes of salvaging the film
Norton stepped in and began working with
K but they were constantly at odds with
one another however many of Norton's
edits did wind up in the Final Cut of
the film it was a new experience for
Norton but the skill came in handy later
he ended up co-editing the 2005 Neo
Western down in the valley a film he
also starred in after filming wrapped on
American History X director Tony K was
very bitter towards Edward Norton and he
wasn't shy about letting the media know
his thoughts the telegraph quotes him
saying that Norton is a narcissistic
dilettante obsessed with his image of
best with screen time I was going to
take Hollywood by storm and I would have
but for that buffoon keep in mind K
doesn't seem particularly modest himself
I'm a Storyteller so you know making a
television commercial is
is telling a story of sorts thanks to
all the drama behind the scenes during
the filming of American History X Norton
earned a reputation for being difficult
to work with but the actor rejects that
characterization as he told the
telegraph difficult is really a question
of semantics you can use that word or
you can say rigorous committed you can
put it other ways and I'll tell you a
very true thing none of what I would
call the genuine talents I've worked
with directors have ever called me
difficult in a 2014 interview with Dan
Rather Edward Norton confessed that
making American History X was really
hard it was it was a gorilla kind of
experience
Norton put in some serious hours at the
gym to convincingly play Derek as men's
workout reports the actor gained 30
pounds of muscle in just three months
the magazine quotes Norton is saying I
knew this guy was going to have to be
really physically fearsome and defined
by rage arming himself against his own
emotional pain and this body he's
created is the physical manifestation of
that after the film was released people
suddenly perceived Norton as bigger
stronger and more intimidating as he
said on the Tim Ferriss show in 2016
doing that film created the strangest
Distortion of perception on me he went
on to say it's unbelievable the degree
to which that film and the magic of
camera and art in black and white
photography and all these things made a
lot of people think that I was a larger
and tougher person than I am it sounds
like Edward Norton has never been too
concerned about box office returns he'd
much rather participate in films that
make a real cultural impact to hear him
say it American History X is a film that
really managed to capture the Zeitgeist
and he's proud to have been a part of it
in 2010 he told slash film a lot of
films are more successful financially
than fight club or American History X
but those films meant more to people and
continue to to me if I can make a couple
of films that looking back people say
yeah that's what our generation felt
like at that moment that's a good
document then I'm content in a 2016
interview with bet Norton was asked
whether he thinks the issue of racism
has changed since making the film 1998
he responded
to a degree we're not often comfortable
acknowledging this this current of of
racism sits under the surface
he added that anxiety is often the cause
of those feelings same people quote have
anxieties and they look for a Target
Derek goes through quite a dramatic
personal transformation in American
History X and that journey is one of the
things that really excited Edward Norton
about the character as he told Charlie
Rose in 1998
yeah
he goes on to explain that it's not even
so much just the one very extreme
manifestation of this guy but more the
emotional distance that he travels but
Norton had to do more than convincingly
portray Derek's hatred he also had to
create a nuanced character who could
learn how to become a more open-minded
person throughout the course of the film
ultimately Norton interpreted Derek
Vineyard as a classically tragic figure
let's look at someone who ruins all of
the potential in his life because of
Rage Norton also wanted audiences to see
something of themselves in Vineyard
despite the extreme and extremely ugly
nature of his character in 1999 he told
the guardian an all too common reaction
to something like racism is to hate the
act so much you dismiss the person but
in this film you're forced to confront
the complexity of the character and his
tragedy
watching American Horror Story is scary
enough but how does the cast feel as
they bring these stories to life AHS
seems to make a permanent impact on its
Stars sometimes for the better and
sometimes for the worst here's how the
show has changed these actors lives in
the early years Evan Peters was
basically the face of American Horror
Story he started out playing Tate
Langdon in the first season and went on
to star in seven more seasons of the
creeped out Anthology show it seemed
like pizzas would always be in the cast
but that didn't turn out to be the case
in 2019 Peter shocked fans for the
announcement that he wouldn't be
returning for 1984 the ninth season of
AHS I'm making hard choices
every day honestly he probably didn't
miss out on much I just needed to get
each one of you along with
why
so I can kill you prior to Peter's
announcement the actor revealed that AHS
was taking a toll on his mental health
telling GQ in 2018 I don't like to yell
and scream I actually hate it I think
it's disgusting and really awful Horror
Story sort of demanded that of me
he went on to explain it's just
exhausting it's really mentally draining
and you don't want to go to those places
ever in your life and so you have to go
there for the scenes and it ends up
integrating it somehow into your life
Jessica Lange began her stints on
American Horror Story in season one
portraying Constance London Tate's
malignant mother the role ushered in a
whole new phase of Lang's career winning
her a second Primetime Emmy she stuck
with AHS for three more seasons
eventually returning for Apocalypse to
reprise her role as Constance honestly
no one plays an intimidating matriarch
quite like her bandidamer
they started with small animals too
until they graduated before getting that
career-changing phone call from Ryan
Murphy Lang was going through a
difficult breakup she had just ended a
30-year relationship with actor and
playwright Sam Shepard and had no idea
what she'd do next in 2019 she told gold
Derby going into that series somehow
revitalized me and made me understand
that there was a whole way of working
that I had never done before it forced
me to work in a way with complete and
total abandon the story checks out
was tired of being Typecast she felt
like casting directors only saw her as a
girl next door type so when Ryan Murphy
offered her the role of powerful witch
Madison Montgomery she left at the
chance
we submit to you Body and Soul the lord
of the underworld we offer you our
obedience and everlasting devotion
playing mata's son clearly gave Roberts
a new sense of confidence as she told
Kalida it's definitely made me more of a
Fearless actress things I would normally
say no to I'm more like bring it on her
stint on AHS has certainly opened doors
for her too in another interview with
collider she noted I remember before
Madison I would go up to parts and
they'd be like she's too sweet or she's
too nice now after Madison no one says
that it's easy to see why I mean why
wait for some phony happily ever after
when you can have your piece now I say
what about you Luke
Lady Gaga always wanted to break into
acting long before her music career ever
took off for proof looked no further
than her bit role on this Sopranos
episode she put those acting Ambitions
on the back burner for a long time but
Ryan Murphy ultimately helped turn that
dream into a reality he casts her as a
vampiric countess in American Horror
Story Hotel I lived in New York many
years ago I loved roaming the streets
devouring the pulse of the city
electrifying as Murphy told billboard in
2015 she has always wanted to be an
actress she studied it in college but
she was too terrified to go on auditions
when Murphy showed her footage of one of
her scenes in AHS Gaga reportedly began
to sob Murphy told billboard I was
worried but she told me later that it
was because she was so happy that
somebody had believed in her Gaga's new
found confidence as an actress changed
her entire career she went on to stara's
Alley alongside Bradley Cooper in the
2018 remake of A Star is Born which was
nominated for several Academy Awards and
won best original song for shallow
American Horror Story freak Show
wouldn't have been complete without
Twisty the clown the terrifying
character was played by actor John
Carroll Lynch and it was his first time
ever working on the show The Character
had a rather nasty habit of sneaking up
on people and killing them and the fact
that twisty barely spoke a word made him
more than more frightening that proved
to be quite an actually challenge for
Lynch who had to rely solely on body
language for the performance as he told
collider in 2014 there are a lot of
things I've never tried before because a
character is silent there was a
challenge of being told there's almost
no dialogue and we're gonna take away
half of your face let's see if you can
act in those circumstances judging by
his nightmare inducing performance as
twisty would say he nailed it and became
a more versatile actor in the process
in 2018 Cody Fern joined American Horror
Story for Apocalypse he memorably played
Michael Langdon otherwise known as the
Antichrist to prepare for the path and
get into the mindset of a ghoulish
entity like Michael Fern spent lots of
time reading up on theology psychology
and philosophy Michael has been Fern's
biggest role to date and apparently Fern
still hasn't entirely moved on from the
character in June 2019 he told God Derby
people have more of an interest in the
darker aspects of life and I think it's
very much about trying to understand the
darkness within ourselves I'm a serious
actor
for eight years Hugh Laurie starred in
the total role in the [ __ ] medical drama
house but despite becoming an
International Celebrity he isn't chasing
success for its own sake he is why he
hasn't been the same since house
for an actor not every day on the job is
glamorous and exciting sometimes it can
feel a little repetitive so after nearly
a decade playing Dr Gregory Health Hugh
Laurie definitely wanted a change of
scenery he still enjoyed playing the
role all the way through to the final
season but the root scene was starting
to get monotonous and he wasn't sure if
he was really cut out for that kind of
commitment anymore as the final season
was airing he told the telegraph you
know we have done 170 episodes now I
think that's about 50 to 60 feature
films worth you want to break you really
do so Laurie's first order of business
after house wrapped was to take a long
break from acting he ended up spending a
full three years away from Hollywood
save for a few small exceptions like
lending his voice to the video game
LittleBigPlanet 3. he finally got back
in front of the camera in 2015 for the
Disney film Tomorrowland he loved
playing house but he often felt like he
was working himself to the bone on set
getting up at 5am for a 16-hour work day
was not uncommon when he stuck with his
schedule for nearly a decade no wonder
he needed an extended vacation once the
camera stopped rolling how are things in
hell is the humidity the big issue
although Lori would certainly have
preferred more privacy than the Press
afforded him after the success of house
the overwhelming praise for the series
gave him a major confidence boost after
all he'd never been part of such an
internationally successful show before
previously he occasionally felt insecure
about his career because he'd never gone
to drama school and wondered if he
wasn't a genuinely qualified actor
Laurie used to question whether or not
he really belonged in the entertainment
industry but once house took off with
audiences and you saw the impact the
show was having he realized that he
definitely earned his place it was a
huge turning point in his career as he
told the guardian house was something I
didn't have to apologize for it was
something I was really proud of and
whether you liked it or not it was
undeniable
although Lori wasn't acting much right
after house went off the air he didn't
completely stop working he just chose to
invest his time in a different creative
Pursuit it turns out he's a talented
Blues musician and he loves recording
music even more than he loves acting in
2011 Lori released let them talk his
first Blues album he was surprised by
the success it achieved and he
eventually went on to release a second
album in 2013 entitled didn't it rain he
admitted that he was quite nervous in
the recording studio but as it turned
out he had nothing to be worried about
his concert sold out and the albums were
certified gold he told the guardian in
2013 there's a sensual pleasure involved
in making sounds harmonious sounds that
I just can't get and I don't think
anyone can quite get from acting it just
cannot get better than that it takes
over my whole body in a way the acting
just can't
Dr Gregory House was known for being
prickly and brutally honest but it would
be tough to argue that he was a villain
despite his rough exterior he had a kind
heart and he genuinely wanted to help
his patients but the actor who played
him eventually wanted to play a truly
evil character in 2016 if you Lori
finally got the chance when he landed
the role of Richard Roper on the BBC
series the night manager based on John
the Carrey's novel of the same name the
plot follows a former soldier who
manages to worm his way into ropers in a
circle as Roper is aiming the Egyptian
government in the midst of the Arab
Spring at one point Roper is described
as the worst man in the world and Laurie
was up for the challenge of bringing
this vile character to life he told the
telegraph villene serves a purpose and
all good storytelling it's a very well
trodden path in all kinds of stories so
when I was offered the chance to play
Roper there was no way I could possibly
pass it up a life
depends on the quality of your
performance in the next half hour
so smile
after eight years of Playing House Lori
knew that he could easily land another
doctor role if he wanted to but he felt
like doing so would mean he was
basically putting himself in a box but
when he was offered the part of Dr Eldon
chance on the Hulu series chance he just
couldn't pass it up when asked in a 2016
interview with junkie if he hesitated
before taking another medical role he
answered for about two minutes I opened
the script and thoughts oh this is good
it's a shame I can't do it because it's
medical after three pages I'd have
forgotten Laurie made an exception this
time because doctor chant was a
different type of doctor who was dealing
with very different patients than Dr
house was no I'm not a treating
therapist I'm a Consulting you're a
psychiatrist she answered the medical
drama and a suspenseful thriller or
wrapped up in one and Laurie didn't feel
like he was playing the same role all
over again overall he suddenly changed
in the years since the house finale but
the authenticity that he brings to every
role still makes him one of the best
actors in the business
what goes into portraying a murderer how
did actor Evan Peters prepare for the
role of one of the most notorious Mass
killers in recent history what was Ryan
Murphy's one rule for dramatizing real
life events keep watching to find out
all the details Dahmer monster the
Jeffrey Dahmer story a title which is
only marginally less convoluted than
High School Musical the musical the
series is a Netflix biographical crime
drama about the titular Infamous real
world serial killer Jeffrey Dahmer the
series tells the story through the lens
of those affected by his criminal
activities rather than by focusing on
the murderer himself that alone is a
refreshing take on the genre as most
dramas based on real and dangerous
people toe the line between retelling
events and romanticizing them
fortunately in this case the exact
opposite is occurring as the cast has
been open about their experience with
the production star Evan Peters in
particular has come forward about the
process which saw him become the Killer
and precious little of what he has to
say can be misconstrued by even the most
Ardent True Crime apologists here's what
he shared about the acting process in an
interview shared by Netflix's YouTube
account Evan Peters shared familiar
struggle stating that portraying the
serial killer Jeffrey Dahmer deeply
taxed him he said honestly I was very
scared about all of the things that he
did and diving into that and trying to
commit to that was absolutely going to
be one of the hardest things I've ever
had to do in my life because I wanted it
to be very authentic but in order to do
that I was gonna have to go to really
dark places and stay there for an
extended period of time trivia like this
feels double edged on one hand behind
the scenes information is usually
compelling simply on the Merit that
someone in the know is pulling the
curtain aside so that curious minds can
potentially access it on the other hand
it's not particularly surprising or even
interesting news to hear that a normal
person is disturbed by pretending to be
a serial killer if anything that should
just be the daily litmus test for anyone
taking on these roles the moment it
doesn't phase you it's time to switch
actors right all this aside it's
heartening to know that Peters is
putting in the work to ensure that his
projects are as good as it can possibly
be and maybe that's the only important
takeaway from this because anything else
sounds suspiciously like someone
complaining about one of the coolest
jobs in the world well the role Force
Devin meters to go to some Dark Places
the actor was always wary of making sure
his character was presented in an honest
and very unflattering light that said he
wasn't the only person involved in the
creation of Dahmer monster the Jeffrey
Dahmer story who felt this way going
into the series during the
aforementioned interview with Netflix
Peters revealed that co-creator Ryan
Murphy had one rule with this project
never glamorized the titular serial
killer according to Peters not betraying
Dahmer as a protagonist means that the
audience can't see his point of view and
potentially sympathize with his plight
Peters explained it's called the Jeffrey
Dahmer story but it's not just him and
his backstory it's the repercussions
it's how society and our system failed
to stop him multiple times because of
racism homophobia it's just a tragic
story everybody gets their side of the
story told that it felt important to be
respectful to the victims to the
victim's families overall the goal was
to detail the experiences of his victims
and others involved in the disturbing
case Peter said that dalmer's story is
quote so much bigger than the serial
killer and that's what the show's cast
and crew hopes viewers take away from
the series
sometimes all it takes is one role to
change your career this is especially
true of Sean William Scott who became a
huge star from American Pie his role as
the crude Rude dimwitted Dude Stifler
gained him enough notoriety that would
impact his career forever
before American Pie Sean William Scott
himself was not a particularly
noteworthy performer he had zero feature
film credits to his name and his most
notable forays into performing were
appearing in a Sunny Delight commercial
and an Aerosmith video at age 28 he was
working at the Home Depot and going on
lots of auditions and it was that
conviction that eventually resulted in
American Pie part of his early struggles
can be attributed to how Scott initially
saw himself Scott told NBC in 2008. I
always anticipated having a career in
sports but movies were my passion I was
reminded that I could have a life
outside of being a stressed out
professional athlete I realized I could
use the same work ethic and apply it to
another career that I love I graduated
early
told my coaches I wasn't going to play
sports anymore and moved to LA I got
lucky got a manager and that was that
when Scott was first hired for the role
of Stifler it hadn't been written as a
major character in fact Stifler only had
a passing presence in the story Scott
told Entertainment Weekly in 2019 the
Stifler character was in two or three
scenes and he was written to be such an
hole that I was like I don't even know
if I'd want to play this guy so I was
like I'm going to rewrite a bit of it
make him the guy you hate to love he's
probably insecure he's like the guy who
wants to be loved the most
as it would turn out his Meeker scripted
presence in the production resulted in a
mediocre payday despite portraying a fan
favorite character in the sex comedy
Scott only scored eight thousand dollars
for playing the role
the summer of 1999 began with moviegoers
counting down the days to the First new
Star Wars movie in 16 years by the end
of that season many had shifted to
discussions of the over-the-top ranch of
American Pie a good deal of this talk
involved Sean William Scott who embodied
a classic version of abrasive masculine
immaturity and whose commitment to the
park turned what could have been a
nuisance into a fan favorite Scott's
appeal as Stifler was so strong that it
even lasted well into the various pie
sequels while reviewing 2012's American
Reunion Roger Ebert mentioned his
affinity for Scott's Stifler while
calling him a highlight of the film
Ebert shared Sean William Scott has made
the role of Stifler his own and seems
able to morph his face into an entirely
new person narrowed eyes broad maniacal
grin frightening Focus still with all
the Zeal for seduction and Adventure he
had in high school the Ingenuity with
which he destroys the jet skis of two
jerks can only be admired even in these
more enlightened at times a 2019
retrospective review of the original
American Pie that criticized the
features Politically Incorrect elements
still found time to praise Scott's
performance years removed from when
American Pie first hit theaters Scott
can still drum up enough praise to
remind everyone why he became the film's
biggest breakout star
in the wake of American Pie Scott's
status as an actor was significantly
elevated his first appearance in 2000's
original Final Destination was a brief
one that had him meeting a graphic
demise on screen after that Scott
headlined the Todd Phillips feature road
trip another raunchy comedy the cast him
among a group of students who hit the
road in pursuit of sexual Delights other
roles around this time included Dude
where's my car and evolution all playing
off the dim horny jock Persona he
suddenly had all to himself it's an
age-old Hollywood question do you lean
into your notoriety and risk the
diminishing returns of repetition or do
you try to blaze a unique path and risk
alienating your newfound fans Scott
shared in 2003 about his struggle with
such questions saying I was like nah
being the funny guy that's not why I
came to LA but I appreciated it and I
realized that this is really just a
blessing to be able to make people laugh
when a comedy becomes as successful as
American Pie it's only a matter of time
before talk turns to a sequel pie
presented a pair almost immediately the
first of these arrived in 2001 under the
name American Pie 2. a Smash Hit its
success got American Wedding green LED
which would arrive in 2003. suddenly the
franchise wasn't about teenage sexual
escapades anymore but instead watching
the characters navigate various stages
of young adulthood through it all
Stifler remained an anchor of immaturity
who could always be counted on for crazy
Antics and ill-advised situations
Scott admitted in 2003 I don't know why
people like the character it's because
of the way his friends played off that
character because if they would have
dismissed him and just treated him as
another doll as an audience member you'd
be like whoa he's just a jerk but they
just play with him and they accept what
he does
very unpleasant individual you know that
while films like 2001's Jay and Silent
Bob Strike Back in 2003's Old School
cast Scott in supporting roles he also
got plenty of opportunities to become a
leading man in 2003 he was cast opposite
fellow Rising Star Dwayne The Rock
Johnson and peterberg's so-so The
Rundown he also signed on for 2005's
high-profile reboot of The Dukes of
Hazzard despite a massive ad campaign
Dukes bombed both critically and at the
box office a string of ill-conceived
comedies followed many trying to
recapture that Stiffler magic 2007's
American loser cast him opposite
Gretchen Maul as a rudderless adolescent
adult that same year Mr Woodcock put him
opposite Billy Bob Thornton as an adult
looking to get revenge for his
adolescence 2008's the promotion had
Scott competing with John C Reilly to
get past the Adolescent ways that had
stopped them from advancing in their
careers in 2008 however Scott made a
dent with Paul Rudd on one of his first
star Vehicles Role Models trying to put
some space between his model's character
and Stifler Scott said at the time he's
not really mean to anybody he's actually
a very optimistic guy but clearly the
whole physicality of it and that Vibe is
very similar but I had wanted to add
something that made him a little more
irreverent Role Models earned
significantly better reviews than Hazard
and Scott's other films of this period
and also fared better at the box office
but still now a decade after his
American Pipe breakthrough John William
Scott was still trying to overcome the
same typecasting limitations
like many other comedic actors before
him Sean William Scott tried to Branch
out with more serious films it was a
smart Endeavor but unfortunately it
seems he may have just bet on the wrong
horses his big high-profile leading man
play was undoubtedly Bulletproof Monk
the 2003 film was based on a comic book
it was also the directorial debut of
in-demand music video director Paul
Hunter and starred Chao Yun fat this was
a high-profile action film that had
potential to launch a franchise with
Sean's character as its Luke
skywalker-like hero in training what
could go wrong
to answer that question ask yourself
when was the last time you heard anyone
talk about Bulletproof Monk around the
same time he signed up for what was a
very in-demand movie Southland Tales it
was filmmaker Richard Kelly's feverishly
anticipated follow-up to Donnie Darko a
movie that seemed to have announced the
arrival of Hollywood's newest otura
unfortunately the production became
notoriously troubled the film was
rumored to be largely incoherent and
after years of delays was released with
little Fanfare in more recent years
Scott has appeared in the grisly
Thriller bloodline and the crime drama
already gone but neither of them fared
much better
in 2010 Sean William Scott kicked off a
new decade by connecting with one of the
most prolific names in 1990s Indie
Cinema filmmaker Kevin Smith probably
seemed like a safe bet as did starring
opposite the legendary Bruce Willis what
Scott most likely didn't anticipate
however was a troubled production that
had the original title dropped against
Smith's Wishes the director and leading
man coming to despise each other and the
entire experience being so miserable
that Smith hasn't made a studio film
sense
Scott was however one of the funnier
parts of the finished film despite Cop
Out faring poorly with critics and the
box office it did earn the actor a dream
role well maybe Smith even considered
his collaboration with Scott to be the
inspiration he needed to push hit
somebody a hockey comedy based on a
Warren Zevon song across the goal line
in 2010 Smith explained Sean for me was
the key into the character this dude has
something in him that you can just see
hang so well on buddy he's got some pain
that's going to work out well as you may
have guessed hit somebody has still not
made the leap from the page to the
Silver Screen it was going to be two
movies then one movie again then a
mini-series and eventually Smith just
read the script on his podcast in 2018.
whether the film is ever resurrected and
whether Scott will still play the part
seems doubtful at this point fortunately
if you want to see Scott in the world of
hockey we still have his two goon films
in 2013 Sean William Scott returned to
the role that had made him a household
name with American Reunion it was the
fourth installment of the franchise and
had the American Pie gang return for
more raunchy escapades this gave Scott
the opportunity to return to the role of
Stifler now a decade older but only
marginally wiser
that's perfect Scott didn't need any
compulsion to come back to the franchise
that made him in fact according to him
it was his idea he shared it was a long
time in the making because I pitched the
movie three years ago the idea of
bringing everybody back for a high
school reunion I said three years to go
wow how much fun is it going to be to
play Stiffler in his 30s it was a blast
two decades after his American Pie
breakthrough Scott is still a working
actor although it's hard to argue that
any of his several dozen roles has come
close to Stifler as far as Mass Appeal
and awareness in 2018 he took over the
lead role in the fox cop show Lethal
Weapon though he was coming onto a
program fraught with behind the scenes
drama Scott's presence on the show gave
it a much needed positive boost in
publicity intriguingly Scott apparently
pursued the role himself once he saw
that the show's original lead clayne
Crawford had been fired by the program
though Lethal Weapon with Scott in the
lead role lasted just one season that
wasn't the end of his TV work later in
2021 he'll be back on the Fox network
with welcome to flatch a docu comedy
that aims to be the office for small
town America a comedic project flat
seems like it could represent a
fundamental shift in Scott's career as
he plays an authority figure in the
lives of some younger troublemakers
perhaps this is the beginning of Sean
William Scott Reinventing himself as a
middle-aged actor whose days of
frivolity are behind him
it has now been well over two decades
since Scott's life was changed forever
through the antics of Stifler in
American Pie though it has had its ups
and downs he has insisted that he has no
regrets about the career launching role
Scott said in 2018 I didn't think Martin
scorses he was going to cast me in his
next movie I understood why I wasn't
getting cast for other things I would
have been a distraction I kind of
pigeonholed myself but I felt really
lucky to get the chance to make people
laugh given that the combined worldwide
grosses of his movies have exceeded one
billion dollars it is hard to feel too
bad for Sean William Scott some gambles
have paid off others have not but talk
to any actor and they'll most likely
tell you they'd be happy to have a
decades-long career with more than 30 TV
and film projects under their belt as
Scott himself put it in 2018 I just got
lucky with American Pie that movie gave
me a career
decades after Freddy Krueger's chilling
debut is one of Horror's most notorious
monsters Robert England still credits
his time as the character for taking his
career to new heights however taking on
the role of Freddy Krueger also
completely changed the actor's life
Robert England never set out with the
intention of playing a monster like
Freddy Krueger in fact his earliest work
was in theater and from there he found
himself playing Sidekicks in supporting
roles he also played some unsavory
characters in films like eaten alive and
appeared in controversial movies like
dead and buried but playing Freddy was
an entirely new experience England told
Hollywood Chicago I had gotten typed
early in Hollywood as a southerner then
it was the best friend and sidekick
roles although playing Freddy was a big
step up from his previous Parts England
has said that the reason he got the role
was simply because of Typecast he had
experience working in the horror genre
and this time
he just got to play the main villain
instead of a side character
your big freaking TV but England isn't
resentful of the fact that he was
Typecast as he explained I didn't choose
to be in horror movies I just like to go
where I'm wanted one of the perks of
playing an iconic monster like Freddy
Krueger England may not be winning
Oscars or raking in the biggest salaries
in Hollywood but even though he's in his
early 70s he never finds himself wanting
for work and he has plenty of freedom to
choose the projects He wants England
acknowledges that if he'd never gotten
the opportunity to play Freddy he
probably wouldn't be enjoying the same
level of success today he's been
consistently working in Hollywood since
Landing a supporting role in the 1974
film Buster and Billy but after playing
Freddy the offers started flooding in as
a result he's acted in movies like The
Phantom of the Opera and behind the mask
the rise of Leslie Vernon TV shows like
bones and Supernatural and in 2020 he
hosted a show on the Travel Channel
called true Terror the role literally
opened a whole new world for the actor
he told Lupa I started working abroad
I've done about a dozen movies in Europe
I've done movies in Africa and Russia
have done movies in South America and
Mexico lots of movies in Canada and that
is the greatest gift that was given to
me by the success of The Nightmare on
Elm Street franchise England also
attends conventions around the world he
told den of geek I don't think I'd have
this longevity without the genre I can't
believe I'm still here it keeps changing
and growing and I feel like I'm on
cruise control now I can go where I want
Robert England had been a working actor
for years before playing Freddy but
after Elm Street came out his life
seemed to change overnight and there's
always fans around now I mean the crew
are bringing their kids in and stuff so
I'm kind of on a little bit suddenly
audiences all over the world knew his
name and the film made a huge cultural
impact England told Hollywood Chicago
the Freddy phenomenon was International
I had no control over it I realized it's
best to surrender and enjoy it because
you can't fight it for the first time he
was experiencing what it was really like
to be an international star not just an
actor with a few films and TV shows
under his belt it was a whole new level
of Fame but he simply embraced the
changes and didn't allow it to overwhelm
him in fact England enjoys the attention
especially when it comes to seeing his
name appear in different languages
around the world he told Lupa I really
like foreign posters especially the ones
where my name is written in Russian or
Chinese I think that's cool and some of
them are just amazing there's one from
Thailand A Nightmare on Elm Street 3
Dream Warriors with the Freddy snake
it's a strange creepy poster but it's an
image of me swallowing an oscar-winning
actress so I had to have it Robert
England always knew that what he wanted
to do for the rest of his life was
theater after attending a professional
acting school and working in regional
theater he started to get opportunities
in film but he still valued everything
he'd learned acting in place and when he
got the role of Freddy he was finally
able to put those skills to good use
again there was so much he could express
about Freddie's character through body
language and his theater skills gave him
a leg up he told Looper I learned back
in my theater days that villains are
better written they're more complex
there are more layers and it's fun to do
it when I finally got all that makeup on
and found the voice and found the moves
I realized I didn't have to worry about
what Robert Englund looked like
it's traveling time
fear seems to be an international
language England realized just how well
the narratives in films like Elm Street
could translate across cultures when he
saw the worldwide response to the film
there are certain Primal Terrors that
affect all of us no matter where we're
from and Elm Street played on those
emotions the thought of someone
attacking you in your sleep when you're
most vulnerable and totally defenseless
is an ancient fear one that we've lived
with since Humanity's caveman days
England told movie hole these movies
have traveled so well you don't really
need subtitles with them because they're
not that culturally specific everyone
has this great Primal basic hook which
is the nightmare the bad dream so people
can identify with these films following
Elm Street's success in England accepted
more offers to work on Films shot abroad
where he was able to indulge his love of
travel and history the actor has worked
on movies shot everywhere from Italy to
Israel and he's always been very
grateful that playing Freddy opened up
those doors for him in fact he says that
nowadays he often prefers working abroad
he told IGN I would never have been able
to go down into the caves in the
jordania region and seeing the original
Neanderthal graffiti I would never have
been invited to Lake Balaton in
Czechoslovakia I never would have spent
six weeks putting my makeup on in the
same room that Rasputin was shot in
these are all the things that happened
because I'm Freddy Krueger pure and
simple although England is certainly
best known for his work in horror films
he also enjoys comedy unfortunately the
fact that his name and face were so
strongly associated with Freddy Krueger
in the 80s and 90s meant that comedy
directors weren't exactly knocking on
his door and asking to work with him
audiences knew him as a villain not a
comedian and England knows that he
missed out on some roles because of it
I'm sorry I I kept scaring you but I
work on commission
but at the end of the day he's come to
accept that it was all for the best
England admitted to IGN I think in the
middle 80s there were a couple of gigs
in comedy both as an actor and director
that I lost because I was so so
connected with Freddy Krueger I wish it
hadn't happened however he has no
regrets about pursuing work in the
horror genre and sacrificing some
comedic roles because of that decision
after all no actor can really do it all
and in the long run his career decisions
have clearly worked out in his favor if
you ever found yourself lying awake at
night after watching elms straight
afraid to close your eyes because Freddy
Krueger just might show up in your
dreams you're in good company Elm Street
has resulted in plenty of sleepless
nights for audiences over the years as
well as a few cast members in fact
England himself admits that he's had
nightmares in which he's Freddy wait a
second let me get this straight you're
having nightmares about Freddy
has in me while shooting at night for
the original film England spent hours
and hours wearing the heavy makeup that
created Freddy's frightening look he got
used to seeing himself looking monstrous
but every once in a while he would catch
a glimpse of himself in a mirror at the
end of a long day and feel disoriented
and confused by his own reflection and
that feeling has haunted him for years
England told this bird's day
occasionally I do have a nightmare I
dream of me sitting up and I'm looking
in the mirror and it's not me it's
Freddy in the mirror so yeah that's how
you know a slasher villain is truly
terrifying when the guy behind the mask
is having bad dreams
at this point you could definitely
consider Robert England to be an expert
on horror films in general the genre is
certainly in the midst of a modern
Resurgence and England says that after
so many years of playing creepy
characters he's developed an eye for
Which films will be successful and which
ones will flop so what qualities can
really make or break a horror movie
according to England it all depends on
whether or not the film offers something
genuinely unique he told flavor wire if
something is good or original it does
eventually get discovered it can take a
while but it will rise to the surface
and as you might expect England is glad
that horror is finally getting the
recognition and respect that he's always
believed the genre deserves back in the
1980s he found himself defending horror
films for their artistic Merit because
they weren't taken as seriously and now
the genre has entered a whole new era
for England one of the best parts of
playing Freddy is the fact that younger
Generations still love the Elm Street
films although it's been decades since
the original movie was released Freddy
still scares new audiences today dad
you've got to see this movie it's
totally terrifying that's because it's
based on a true story wait what Freddy's
coming for you you can sleep when you're
dead England credits technological
advances since the first film with its
long-standing appeal although the
continuation of the franchise certainly
didn't hurt either with several Elm
Street films coming out in the years
since the original including the Friday
the 13th crossover Freddy vs Jason fans
had a whole lot of new material to look
forward to England told nerd bastards A
Nightmare on Elm Street came of age at
the same time as MTV early cable and
then VHS generation and the DVD
generation and then Blu-ray and Netflix
so I'm probably on my third generation
of fans by now the actors said that the
digitally remastered versions of the
films represented a significant
Improvement in quality adding the movies
looked better now than when they did
when they came out so there's a great
Advantage I have
you forgot where you came from kid
but I know where you're going
England talked to Lupa about what he's
learned over the years as far as what
their character means to fans saying
I've met thousands of fans whose memory
of Nightmare on Elm Street is not as a
horrible violent film they have great
fond memories of watching it with their
mums and dads and brothers and sisters
they have these memories of a family
experience can Robert England ever
really say goodbye to Freddy Krueger as
of right now his answer is a definite
maybe in 2018 England appeared on the
Halloween episode of the sitcom The
Goldbergs is Freddy it was the first
time that he'd played the character
since appearing in Freddy vs Jason in
2003 but as far as returning to the role
for another movie in the future he's not
sure he can commit to it I need a new
actor to play Freddie because they're
gonna have to do eight of them you know
maybe it's Freddy's I might have one
left in me but at this point it would be
pretty unrealistic to expect England to
sign on to play Freddy in eight more
films actor Jackie Earl Haley took on
the role for one film in a 2010 reboot
but since this is the role that means
more to England than any other there's a
good chance that we'll see him on screen
and in our nightmares as Freddy once
more
[Music]
the role of killmonger took a serious
Talon star Michael B Jordan after
gaining mainstream attention through
films at the heart-wrenching 2013
biographical drama food fail station the
2015 Sports drama Creed and the 2015
reboot of Fantastic Four Jordan joined
the Marvel Cinematic Universe the actor
reunited with his Fruitvale Station and
Creed director Ryan coogler for 2018
Super Smash Hit Black Panther in which
Jordan played Eric killmonger Stevens
AKA killmonger in Black Panther
killmonger is more than just a
run-of-the-mill body who wants to take
down the hero he has a connection to
Chadwick boseman's King t'challa and an
emotionally driven purpose for wanting
to overthrow him as the leader of
wakanda the film reveals that
killmonger's birth name is unjadaka and
that he's a cousin of king t'challa
after t'challa's father the then king of
wakanda to Chaka and the wakandan
Statesman Zari confront killmonger's
father and jobu about his plans to
reveal wakanda's technology to the rest
of the world to Chaka kills and jobu in
order to perpetuate elither and jobu
simply disappeared while undercover
tashaka and Zuri leave and jobu's Son
behind and fly back to wakanda that
child grows up to be killmonger who
eventually becomes a Black Ops Soldier
for the US military before partnering
with Ulysses claw a black market arms
dealer with access to wakandan
technology It's a Long Way to the throne
but killmonger's plan finally ends with
a battle against t'challa that mirrors
the one between their fathers after his
defeat killmonger chooses to die as a
free man rather than be held as a
prisoner for the rest of his life
bury me in the ocean
but my ancestors that jumped from the
ships
because they know death was better than
bondage certainly killmonger is a
character whose roots are planted in
pain and Trauma for Jordan it was
difficult to remain in that headspace
for an extended period of time in a
November 2018 interview on The Bill
Simmons podcast Jordan opened up to the
radio host about the mental weight he
was left with after portraying
killmonger it was one of those things
that I didn't know what was going on I
never was in a character for that long
of a period of time and never was I
guess that dark that lonely that painful
so coming out of it I thought oh yeah
business as usual I can just go back
home I'll cut my hair off and everything
will be back to normal however that plan
didn't exactly pan out Jordan found it
more difficult than he had anticipated
to fully step away from killmonger
According to comicbook.com the actor
needed a month of time in therapy
sessions to fully close the door on the
Black Panther villain Jordan explained I
found myself kind of in the routine of
being isolated and went out of my way to
make sure I was by myself and didn't say
too much more than the usual once I got
finished I dropping the movie it took me
some time to talk through how I was
feeling and why I was feeling so sad and
like a little bit depressed ultimately
Jordan said that reconnecting with
friends and loved ones and talking
things out helped him get back to normal
killmonger might have been a difficult
role for Jordan but it also further
helped Skyrocket him to Superstar him
the same year black panther hit the big
screen Jordan booked two starring roles
in an adaptation of Fahrenheit 451 and
in Creed 2. in 2019 he headlined Justin
Mercy a true story about systemic
problems in the criminal justice system
Jordan is also moving behind the camera
and producing new shows including
Netflix's superhero origin story raising
Dion in which he coasts out as a
scientist named Mark Warren while the
movie industry remains more or less on
hold as of the making of this video
Jordan has some exciting projects lined
up and nonetheless Bianca's late 2020
release without remorse he's set to team
up with Kugler once again for wrong
answer a film about cheating scandals in
Atlanta's Public Schools additionally
Jordan is set to star in a new remake
make of The Thomas Crown Affair among
other more secretive projects if you
want to relive Jordan's Journey as
killmonger black panther is streaming on
Disney plus now
over the years jar jar Bings has become
emblematic of the Star Wars prequel era
as well as the totem the internet holds
up to argue how terrible those three
films were in the Years following the
release of The Phantom Menace fans
denounced jar jar AS little more than a
cheap money grab made to sell toys and
that was at best at worst they described
him as all the worst aspects of Star
Wars distilled into one character with
some critics suggesting the character
represented a racist stereotype on
account of his cartoonish accent
no Mrs stay Mr Godzilla pinks missing
your humble servant at the center of all
this though was the man who portrayed
judger armored best when he was cast for
the first Star Wars movie almost 20
years ago best was coming off a
celebrated turn in the hit musical stomp
in San Francisco and in 1997 Bess went
into production on The Phantom Menace
with bright eyes and a cheerful attitude
it's easy to see how much fun he had
behind the scenes of The Phantom Menace
II singing dancing and chipper as ever
even when he was draped in latex drawing
a searing Tunisian summer but all that
changed in May 1999. practically
everybody was around back then was aware
of the fun backlash against the
inclusion of Jar Jar Binks in Star Wars
Canon and In fairness best overwrought
Buster Keaton impression didn't exactly
fit well into her film all about taxes
and trade confrontations even so however
it's easy to forget today just how toxic
that backlash became a number of hate
websites cropped up on the Internet
wishing all kinds of horrible things
upon the character even major news
entertainment Outlets run stories about
the frothing hate against jar jar that's
over time gradually became more and more
disturbing some Star Wars fans even LED
calls for gungun genocide comments which
were probably intended to be humorous
but which nonetheless feel particularly
unfunny in this day and age it's not
that jar jar Bings was just unliked or
even hated it's that so many people
relish the idea of Exterminating
something that only existed as a
fictional construct to his credit George
Lucas warned best ahead of time that
there might be anger in response to Jaja
the same way there had been to the Ewoks
in Return of the Jedi and for what it's
worth Lucas also publicly defended best
when the backlash turned out to be much
much worse and either of them could have
imagined sadly however people can only
hold up against so much public
vilification for so long after taking
about as much as anyone could be
expected to take best became suicidal in
July 2018 the actor revealed in a
Twitter post that he nearly decided to
jump off a bridge due to the media
backlash against Jaja a backlash that
still affects his career today so months
later he opened up in Greater detail how
the harassment he faced for playing Jar
Jar Binks pushed him to consider suicide
I just wanted to play a part I was
exhausted
over the last 20 years Star Wars fans
have had plenty of time to reflect on
their successes and failures of the
prequel movies and for many of the
people who were around when The Phantom
Menace was released it's given them a
chance to realize that jar jar isn't
exactly a treasonous crime against Star
Wars but that reassessment came empathy
and an online responses the best
confession many apologize for getting
wrapped up in the frenzied fever of Jar
Jar hate fortunately best bad experience
for the Star Wars Universe hasn't put
him off making a long overdue return in
2020 lucasfilm will debut Star Wars Jedi
Temple challenge a kids game show
featuring a range of physical challenges
and contests all of it will be hosted by
best himself still though it's lucky
things turned out so well sometimes it's
easy to forget that the Star Wars movies
are made by people with real lives and
feelings performing their craft
earnestly in good faith best story is
proof that everyone would be far better
off if fans took that to heart if you or
anyone you know is having suicidal
thoughts please call the National
Suicide Prevention Lifeline at 1-800-2
73 talk
Tom Holland is one of the biggest young
stars in Hollywood today the 25 year old
actor was catapulted into International
stardom when he first suited up a
Spider-Man in 2016's Captain America
Civil War joining the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is a Surefire way to join the
Hollywood A-list and Holland was no
exception you're a kid
since becoming an Avenger the British
actor has had the chance to show off his
acting jobs in various non-superhero
films including the critty war drama
Cherry this 2021 flag proved to be
Holland's biggest departure from the
wholesomeness of the MCU it follows a
young former soldier who struggles with
PTSD after returning home from fighting
in Iraq playing such a troubled and
nuanced character was quite the
challenge for Holland too who has since
revealed just how much of a toll the
film took on his health in an interview
with British GQ Tom Holland revealed the
health difficulties he faced filming
Cherry production began with the scenes
depicting Holland's character in The
throes of addiction and his appearance
had to reflect that revealing that his
trainer told him to eat only 500
calories a day and run 10 miles Holland
remembered I lost around 27 pounds by
running in a bin bag every day well this
would be a difficult turn for any actor
it was made worse by the need to bulk
back up again for his scenes as an army
medic Holland shared it was brutal I got
very sick actually and it's changed my
relationship with food completely the
experience was so grueling that Hollands
are sworn off doing anything similar in
the future in the same interview with GQ
he said I think I would find it very
difficult to find a role that would
warrant that sort of abuse on my body
again Holland elaborated this role took
me to some of the darkest places I've
ever been emotionally physically
anythingly I would never go back there
again not for anyone I am pleased I did
it but that door is now closed and
locked engaging in such an intense
physical transformation for a role is
difficult for any actor while Holland
may not be taking on such projects again
many other actors have undergone brutal
Transformations for the sake of their
art Christian Bale for example might be
the star best known for his jaw-dropping
physical Transformations he shocked
audiences in the 2004 Thriller The
Machinist playing an emaciated Insomniac
the actor lost 66 pounds for the roll
and was fully committed to truly
capturing his character shockingly just
six months after filming wrapped on The
Machinist Bale had to bulk up to play
Bruce Wayne in the first of Christopher
Nolan's Batman movies Batman Begins the
actor quickly gained weight after his
machinist roll so much so that Nolan
asked Bale to actually lose weight yet
again Bale later told train magazine I
gained too much weight in the run-up to
Batman Begins I wasn't the size that
Christopher Nolan wanted so I had to cut
down 20 pounds or so just before
shooting I was a lot beefier at first
and this was far from the last time Bale
rapidly changed his physique he went
through a similarly rapid transformation
for 2010's the fighter playing a man
addicted to crack cocaine though a
pattern was emerging Bale has shared
that he didn't actively seek out such
physically grueling roles he told MTV
News I didn't take this job because I
went oh there's a physical
transformation needed I always go damn
there's a physical transformation needed
Tom Holland and Christian Bale are far
from the only actors who have undergone
extreme physical Transformations for a
role of course with the likes of Matthew
McConaughey she Charlize Theron and
Joaquin Phoenix also known for
dramatically changing their appearances
to suit a character of course you've got
to admire these styles for their
commitment to their craft though it's
hard to Envy them for the told it takes
on their bodies and nobody could blame
Holland for passing on the chance to do
it again
from High School Musical to portraying
one of the most infamous serial killers
of the 20th century playing Ted Bundy
took a toll on Zac Efron's body and mind
actors in binding psychopaths are
nothing new when it comes to cinema and
television the horror genre is filled
with a counterclastic examples but there
has always been a Sinister and
uncomfortable feeling when watching
real-life monsters come to life through
the wonders of performance in ephron's
case the mental anguish he endured in
embodying Ted Bundy became a struggle to
maintain his own mental health in such a
dark headspace one of the most bizarre
things about Ted Bundy was his ability
to fit into society in the 1970s and his
polished looks have often been cited as
one of the tools used to hide his
Sinister actions conscious of this
detail Zac Efron worked hard to change
aspects of his physical appearance to
capture the criminal's look in an
interview with Entertainment Weekly the
actor was asked about his process for
creating Bundy's look and replied we got
super specific with Ted's look I lost a
lot of weight for the role on all the
footage I could see Ted was always not
emaciated but was kind of a 70s cineweep
off I worked to learn how to talk with
new teeth in I completely went on my
exercise bike every morning and would
watch kind of heavy stuff Efron
described the process of filming his
quote down and dirty and that much of
his time working on the film was on set
in Kentucky Ephron elaborated in this
movie we spent a lot of time in jail and
I officially know that's as much time as
I want to spend there it was only a
couple of hours but it's shocking Zac
Efron's commitment to imbuing mental
life into Ted Bundy was another obstacle
that presented challenges speaking to
metro.co.uk at the film's European
Premiere he was asked how he limited the
mental toll of the part he replied that
needing to remove himself from his
character so strictly was a new
experience for him and that it was
incredibly difficult he elaborated I
would like to say I separated myself
successfully but I couldn't when asked
if the movie and his performance
glamorized the psychopath he stated that
he tried not to romanticize such an evil
and violent person however Ephron
admitted that he was fascinated by the
opportunity to try and enter the mind to
Bundy as well as Bundy's former
girlfriend Elizabeth Kendall he
explained it's a different perspective
and not your run-of-the-mill serial
killer cliche body count gets high
Higher and Higher and oh the guy you
always know did it film it was what it
was like to be there on the day can you
hear my chains dangling no I can't
well watching everyone's acting in the
film it is both strange and a bit
disturbing to notice how a performer can
so convincingly recreate a notorious
serial killer whose actions still cause
so much pain for the families of his
numerous victims it was not a role
without pain and discomfort for The
Talented actor and he made a bold
decision to move forward with it
decades and CIS has become one of the
most popular franchises in television
history making headlines every time a
new spin-off series is announced such as
the upcoming NCIS Hawaii and every time
an old spin-off series is canceled like
NCIS New Orleans but while drama is the
name of the game with NCIS the biggest
drama in the show's history actually
happened off-screen and the biggest
headlines weren't about spin-offs but
about meltdowns the issue the sudden and
shocking departure of series star Polly
peret peret of course was one of the
show's Mainstays right from the pilot
episode in 2003 playing quirky fan
favorite lab technician Abby shooter but
in 2018 after 15 Seasons peret suddenly
left the show to the surprise of fans
around the world making her final
appearance in the season 15 finale
episode two steps back her departure was
made even more shocking when just after
the episode aired peret posted several
tweets alleging a toxic workplace
environment sang in part I've been
supporting anti-bullying programs
forever but now I know because it was me
if it's school or work that you're
required to go to it's horrifying I left
multiple physical assaults I really get
it now stay safe nothing is worth your
safety tell someone so what happened
according to the rap the behind the
scenes drama stemmed from an incident in
2016 where series star Mark Harmon
reportedly brought his dog to the NCIS
set the dog then attacked a crew member
biting them in the face luckily though
the bite was near the eye and there was
no loss of vision the crew member had to
receive 15 stitches what happened to you
I was attacked by a vicious dog ah are
you okay paret reportedly demanded that
the dog not be allowed on set anymore
and as a result CBS Executives
reportedly asked Harman to keep the dog
in his trailer this led detention
between the two stars who reportedly
agreed to no longer film scenes together
which is why their characters rarely
appeared on screen together in season
15. but that apparently didn't solve
things in 2019 after fans implored her
to return to the series she tweeted no I
am not coming back ever please stop
asking I am terrified of Harmon and him
attacking me I have nightmares about it
in a since deleted tweet peret posted a
photo of the injuries suffered by the
crew member from the dog bite and said
this happened to my crew member and I
felt like hell to keep it from happening
again to protect my crew and then I was
physically assaulted for saying no and I
lost my job according to TMZ the
physical assault occurred when Harmon
allegedly body checked paret which she
believed to be an intentional Act of
intimidation and retaliation for the dog
bite incident but her beef apparently
wasn't just about the dog it was a
culmination of events and it wasn't just
with Harmon but with the producers who
she felt empowered him in 2020 she
tweeted there are things so racist and
so misogynistic and so homophobic and
cruel that were set on set at that show
that I have never spoken of because the
language is so hurtful and y'all
wondered why I quit those producers are
still there all of them including him
whatever the specifics though peret has
seemingly moved on though she has shut
the door on an NCIS reunion she has
mended fences with CBS after they
praised her for working to ensure a safe
workplace environment she has also since
declined to discuss Mark Harmon and her
departure from the show instead focusing
on new Endeavors and in 2020 she
returned to CBS to star in the comedy
series broke though it was canceled
peret praised The Experience saying that
the show quote healed her oh my God
Gucci while it's sad to think that peret
will never return to NCIS If Leaving an
unhealthy work environment and finding a
more positive experience on another show
has helped paret heal and restore her
passion for acting then that's what's
important fans may be disappointed by
the unlikelyhood of Abby's reunion but
we're all excited to see what peret does
next
[Music]